[Musique]
les trucs de l'astronome on n'y comprend
rien allez bien
croyez vous
fait comme nous c'est compris
[Musique]
allez centre
kim est arrivé
je suis mort qui veut dire que tout ça
n'est qu'un rêve
non de souvenirs
tous ceux qui sont dans le coma viennent
au même endroit
lire ici en commun certaines personnes
développent des capacités uniques pour
découvrir leur qualité les gens ont
besoin d'un coup de pouce
essayons de voir si étrange si
particulier
j'étais sur le balcon chef il nous a
appris à survivre ici
nous sommes là pour une raison tous les
gens présents n'avaient pas vraiment
réussi dans la réalité n'a pas encore
compris d'oublier règle doit c'est moi
qui ai tiré cesser
si ce monde est fait de souvenirs
ce qu'ils arrivent ici non attention
yann affirme qu'il ya une île dans coma
où il n'y a pas un seul chauffeur
on est toujours à la recherche de ceux
qui peuvent nous aider
ma vie est ici maintenant
bien que je pouvais pas être avec celui
que je mène
dc oui
ce monde n'a jamais été capable de
mettre en valeur les projets originaux
et insolites
pourquoi aurait-on besoin de la réalité
après ça il faut qu'on se réveille
matt réveiller tu comprends
ton corps est ici à commun tués
3 rien y changer la vie dans le coma est
tout aussi réel
et lance là
[Musique]